هذا الاتفاق السياسي والايطالي لم يحضر
باجماعا داخل المكونات المدنيه حيث وافقت
عليها اطراف ورفضته تحالفات مدنيه اخرى
ومن ابرز هذه المكونات قوى اعلان الحريه
والتغيير مجموعه المجلس المركزي وهي التي
وقعت اليوم الاتفاق الايطالي مع المكون
العسكري وقواء اعلان الحريه والتغيير
الكتله الديمقراطيه وهي تحالف يطرح العوده
الى الوثيقه الدستوريه لسنه 2019 كما يرفض
الاتفاق الموقعه اليوم وتحالف نداء اهل
السودان للوفاق الوطني والذي يرفض الاتفاق
ايضا ويصفه بالهزيل كما يرفض الاتفاق
تحالف التغيير الجذري اما تنسيقيات لجان
المقاومه فشهده انقسامات ما بين من تبنى
التغيير الجذريه والعمليه السياسيه
رحبت الخارجيه الامريكيه بتوقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي في السودان واعتبرته خطوه نحو
تشكيلي حكومه الانتقاليه بقياده المدنيه
واكد بيان للوزاره ان الولايات المتحده
وشركاءها يعتبرون جهود تشكيل حكومه بقياده
مدنيه في السودان عملا اساسيا لاستئناف
المساعدات الدوليه
في الاثناء وقد شهدت مناطق في العاصمه
السودانيه الختوم خروج احتجاجات دعت اليها
ما تعرف بالجان المقاومه رفضا للاتفاق
السياسي الموقعه بين قوى مدنيه مجلس
السياده
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره
اسامه سيد احمد اسامه بدايه عن هذه
التظاهرات التي خرجت رفضا للاتفاق ما
التفاصيل
طبعا الاتفاق السياسي الايطالي الذي تم
توقيعه قبل ساعات في القصر الجمهوري
السوداني وجد طبعا بطبيعه الحال ردود
افعال متباينه ما بين الرفض والقبول هنا
واحده من مظاهر الرفض لهذا الاتفاق همم
اعلنته تنسيقيات لجانا المقاومه في بدايه
الخرطوم التي دعت لهذه التظاهره رفضا لهذه
التسويه سياسيه التي تمت اا تم تم توقيعها
بالقصر الجمهوري همم باعتبار ان هذه
التسويه او غير يعني لا تحظى بتوافق سياسي
كما انها ليست مناسبه لاستمراضيه الفتره
الانتقاليه هناك يعني مواجهات همم حدثت
قبل قليل ما بين قوات من الشرطه التي كانت
ترتكزه في محيط القصر الرئاسي
والمتظاهرين واخذت هذه المواجهات
اشكلا من الكرو والفار استخدمت فيها قوات
الشرطه الغاز المسيء للدموع وخراطيم
المياه طبعا هذه هذا هو موقف عبرت عنه
تنسيقيات لجان المقاومه في بدايه الخرطوم
عبر اا يعني تبنيها ودعوتها لهذه
التظاهرات التي شاركت فيها العديد من
الجهات الرافضه لهذا الاتفاق طبعا هذا
الاتفاق لم يجد يعني انه القبول
هذه التظاهره حتى الان يعني مستمره هناك
كما ذكرت مواجهات ما بين قوات الشرطه
والمتظاهرين يعني الوجهه التي حددها
حددتها تنسيقيات لجان المقاومه عبر هذه
عبر هذه التظاهره هي الوصول الى القصر
الجمهوري حيث تم ال اا التوقيع على
الاتفاق الايطالي كرمزيه ضروريه بالنسبه
للمتظاهرين لايصال الرساله لرسالتهم
الرافضه لهذه همم لهذا الاتفاق
شكرا لك اسامه سيد احمد مراسل الجزيره كنت
معنا من الخرطوم